le gouvernement aujourd'hui à profiter
de ces pandémies pour accélérer le
processus de casse du service public
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation de
saturation absolue on réclame des
embauches mais on était déjà dans la rue
avant la pandémie on à 1500 postes qui
correspondent aux heures supplémentaires
que font les soignants plus tous les
postes qui sont supprimés en 2020 en
pleine pandémie alors que le
gouvernement disait il faut qu'on ait
plus de soignants on ferme les écoles
d'infirmiers autant de responsabilités
au sein de l'hôpital autant de
conditions de travail épouvantables et
en plus est précaire dans son dans sa
vie donc on nous dise pas qu'on fait
tout pour rendre attractif le métier
pour embaucher c'est pas vrai
[Musique]